[Music]
this is an escape from everyone's real
life in the past we didn't have real
lives we didn't have responsibility
people didn't have kids now we want to
escape that and we went hard for a month
straight do we revisit the Snooki of any
relationship at all baby nah but saying
old things do come up you know because
that's we're together and that's gonna
happen you know it's a teaser it's a
trailer so a little editing chopping and
screwing going on there too huh Mike I
don't want to downplay it though some
old things still come up but at the same
time I'm pretty sure her marriages are
going out in Miami and being in a
relationship it's pretty hard set the
record straight
are you dating are you single are you
using the smoosh room so I wasn't using
this mushroom on the show because I was
in a relationship on the show currently
I'm not because that was actually a
couple months ago so I do have someone I
really care about that she's the girl
that I was with but currently didn't
work out so I'm single did this show
affect their relationship at all
slightly but there was problems
beforehand and then this is the type of
thing that like could really be the
straw that breaks the camel's back
not because I'm out there doing anything
you don't talk to the person for a month
because you don't have a cell phone you
don't have a TV you don't have an immune
occation so you're like hauling them
every other day you don't mean the duck
on the duck phone came and hear them
plus we had a long-distance relationship
she's from California from New York
which should already be impossible for
somebody you know what I mean so a lot
of things just was made us be like let's
just can't happen right now maybe down
the line I hope that the logistics work
out one day so we can be the one thing
that you're a little bit anxious or
nervous for people to see play out I
will say that you know being in a
relationship was like was was kind of
tough like to be in a club every single
night via alcohol every single night I
didn't do anything but like just being
in that position and then you know
talking on the phone and you know
explaining like I was in a club till
6:00 in the morning every night like
that gets a little sticky I know that I
did the right thing and that's all that
matters
what about Angelina coming back that
looks like that maybe stirs some drama
up in the house
oh yeah and everything was fine and then
one day we get that knock on the door
and we're like oh my god I'm TVs smart
so I had to share a room with her I was
like I need this girl out of here like
so she comes in and she makes like we
called a Staten Island dump and the
Staten Island dump does not disappoint
she takes a dump all over the house
[Music]